In China, President Xi Jinping and US Secretary of State John Kerry...
...meet and reaffirm their commitment to ensure North Korea...
...ends its nuclear weapons program.
Fresh clashes between troops and outlawed PKK militants in Turkey's southeast...
...claim 23 lives.
The United Nations General Assembly holds a minute of silence to honor the victims...
...of the Holocaust during International Holocaust Remembrance Day.
Hundreds of Iraqi asylum seekers are returning home,...
...frustrated by the slow asylum process in Germany.
And finally from Kenya, the presidents of Nigeria and Somalia...
...join their Kenyan counterpart in a memorial ceremony...
...for soldiers killed by al-Shabab Islamists.